is
the teams have now arrived and Qatar is
looking its best to host the biggest
sporting tournament on Earth
but little has gone smoothly in the
build up to this world cup
in a last minute surprise announcement
it's been decided that beer will not be
sold in stadiums on Match days
football fans will still be able to buy
alcohol in fan zones and hotel bars
around Qatar but the late decision to
ban it in grounds goes against
everything that FIFA and the Qatari
organizers had been promising in the
build-up to this tournament
so you won't be allowed to drink beer in
the stadium that's very very well very
bad thing because we love beers when the
game is gonna be hard you have to drink
something to to scream to to go more
emotional it's very complicated for us
like uh we are Mexican we need to feel
like we need building in the stadium to
see come on let's go we can make the
party widow without alcohol so probably
we want it but you can live without
without a beer
FIFA has confirmed the decision but has
given no reason for it but Qatar has
pressured them to keep alcohol branding
to a minimum and there are few overt
signs around the city
in response Budweiser tweeted this
and then deleted it
FIFA and the Qatari organizers had
promised
many many times that alcohol would be
served in the stadiums
and so to go and reverse that decision
what less than 36 hours before the
tournament kicks off
looks at best chaotic at worst
disingenuous
England and Wales were in training again
today they both played their first group
matches on Monday Wales faced the United
States and England will kick off their
campaign against Iran and Al Khalifa
stadium in Doha
the players are not letting themselves
get distracted
hopefully with um
with them not being able to drink we can
perform on the pitch to give them that
sort of excitement and and Buzz a few
England fans have landed but Doha still
feels pretty quiet
thousands of supporters are expected to
arrive over the weekend though
the build up has been muted and largely
dominated by controversy but soon the
focus will switch to the football
Sky News in Qatar